there are several cool and weird
discoveries and stories to come across
in assassin's creed valhalla
some are structured as multi-part quests
while others are just
random findings that you want to go
looking for there are way too many to
list but we've compiled a few of our
favorites we'll try to avoid spoilers as
best we can
but we do have to mention the names of
certain characters and places just to
let you know where to go
in order to find whatever we're talking
about
over the course of the game more people
want to come and join avor settlement in
england one of them being
vulka from your home back in norway
you'll need a level 3 settlement to
convince her to come and join you
but when she does make sure to build her
hut as soon as you can and follow her
quest line
she'll brew you a potion and you'll be
transported to asgard
yep you heard me and actually asgard is
a huge part of the game and surprisingly
easy to miss so consider this your psa
as per tradition a great deal of
valhalla is someone in the present day
using an animus to relive the memories
of someone in the past
unlike the older games in the series
however valhalla doesn't pull you out of
the animus all that often
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't just
hop out every once in a while
i went through hell to bring you here
it'd better be worth it
there's actually a gold mine of lore to
pick through in the modern day
especially on layla's laptop
it's in old files emails and audio
recordings that you'll see additional
context
for valhalla's overall theme that of
fate
leila can talk to her allies as well and
the two will usually have new things to
talk about after significant
developments
in avor story the game won't tell you
about this though if you want to hear
those conversations you'll need to
choose to leave the animus on your own
also make sure to root through layla's
emails you'll find a nod to a certain
global pandemic in there
though avor only teams up with the
hidden ones in order to root the order
of ancients out of england and make the
country safer for their clan they can
take a few more additional steps towards
joining the group
like donning the robes of england's
hidden ones there are actually two
different assassin based armor sets in
the game
the first the hidden one armor increases
your assassination and headshot damage
each armor piece is located in one of
the hidden one bureaus scattered across
england to find them you'll have to
think like a member of the brotherhood
and take into account the history of
england look for the centers of power
back when rome still ruled
england if you're having trouble you can
find a few clues to the bureau's
locations as layla in the modern day
the second the mentor armor allows you
to dress as the leader of the hidden
ones increasing attack power and overall
speed
there is no deductive reasoning for
figuring out where the pieces of the
mentor armor are hidden
but you don't have to guess entirely
like other armor sets finding at least
one
piece and looking at the description of
that piece will tell you where the
others are
if you travel to the forest in the
northeastern part of grant bridgeshire
at night you may be able to spot
fireflies these bright little bugs are
both hard to find
and very fast but if you manage to catch
them you can bring them to the pond
behind your settlement's longhouse
they'll set your settlement to glow come
night time
deep in the lands of east anglia is a
small ransacked home
an almost mystical aura hangs in the air
and scattered notes tell a frightening
story of a man and his three daughters
it is not a welcoming place but those
willing to press on will find a nearby
tomb
hiding a piece of gear behind a locked
door and the door needs
three keys statue has three large slits
something may fit here a knife or a
dagger
if you're having trouble finding this
place go to the easternmost area of the
kingdom
to actually unlock the door and enter
the crypt you'll need to hunt down the
three daughters best each one in combat
and claim their daggers just be careful
each can command a different element and
they hit
pretty hard they aren't bosses you want
to go up against in the early game
unless you've unlocked some powerful
combat abilities
upon finding stonehenge make sure to
explore the nearby area until you find a
cave go inside it and you'll find a very
cool weapon
excalibur that's right king arthur's
legendary blade is there for you to
claim
an ancient weapon
except it's not as simple as that you
need 11 keys to unlock it some keys are
found by completing platforming
challenges inside caves scattered around
england and others are held by zealots
who serve the order of ancients
if you have no idea what you're
searching for you'll actually have to go
into one of the caves for valka's quest
so that will give you an idea what to
look out for zealots are a bit
easier to find they'll traditionally
stick to main roads so just travel along
the main roads and you'll run into them
eventually
in wessex there's a snake carved into
the hillside no
quest here as far as we can tell but
quite a few snakes spawn here
and there's a treasure located here
though you'll first have to discover a
map that tells you which part of the
snake is hiding the prize you seek
until then the place is just a really
good spot to go in order to hunt snakes
those roman artifacts that you may have
discovered in your journey across
england they can be used to outfit a
museum for your settlement expand the
settlement a few times and it will
attract a rather rambunctious fellow
who's
very enthusiastic about rome evil
have you ever been in love build him a
museum and it will kick off a hunt for
these artifacts as well as a pretty
funny
side story that involves the rivalry
between two collectors
a giant wall protects the northern
border of england from the rest of the
world you can travel along the full
length of it lighting the signal fires
as you go you get an achievement
trophy for lighting all of them plus you
meet a fairly interesting and violent
chap on the wall who will challenge you
to a fight
not a quest there's no reason to travel
the length of the wall and light these
signal fires but it will see you explore
the most northern part of the map which
is a beautiful sight to behold
so there you have it some cool things
from ac valhalla that you might have
missed what were your favorites let us
know in the comments below and for more
on valhalla
including graphics comparisons beginners
tips a review and more
keep it a game spot
[Music]
[Music]
you